[Musica]
buongiorno
desidero cominciare questa chiacchierata
con voi di un mio ricordo infantile
vi ricordate quando si giocava al genio
della lampada che poteva darci tre
desideri da esaudire
quando giocavo con i miei compagni ai
miei compagni io ricevo sempre per ma ne
basta uno vorrei che tutte le persone le
creature del mondo stessero bene che
fossero in armonia e in pace in serenità
senza saperlo
nella mia gioiosa innocenza infantile o
anticipavano un po il pensiero del bene
comune che manifesta rian eisler eisler
ci parla della partnership che nel mio
titolo che tratta parla della relazione
fra esseri umani con la madre natura con
lo spirito nella società e via di
seguito
nella eisler rintraccia due modalità una
di dominio che vediamo alle mie spalle
dove viene esaltata alla violenza la
sottomissione lo stupro anche nell'arte
noi possiamo trasformare queste modalità
di relazione e in prelazioni verso la
partnership qui vedete due immagini da
creta l'unione con il mondo animale e
fra i partner
questo modello interdisciplinare e
interculturale proposto ad arjen eisler
bambina ebrea in fuga dall olocausto e
ora ottantottenne l'avete vista nella
foto attivissima insigne studiosa di
macro storia di cultura ci porta un
infinità energia un'infinita forza un
desiderio ancora di essere attivo come
credo noi che siamo riuniti qui oggi per
migliorare il nostro mondo per portare
il nostro contributo eisler ci ispira
alla pace alla compassione fra persone e
anche degli elementi più personali del
nostro vivere più intimi nelle nostre
relazioni umane insieme a quelle sociali
culturali economiche politiche e
spirituali in questo libro che vedrete
la nostra vita
parla di interconnessione nella famiglia
nella comunità con la madre terra qui ci
sono due immagini che mi sono molto care
vedere la terra da lontano ci mette
sempre un po le cose in prospettiva il
potere della partnership sette modalità
di una relazione per una nuova vita è
una traduzione più recente che abbiamo
pubblicato nella collana al che dirigo
della casa editrice forum e vedete in
copertina un interessante rielaborazione
di un artista friulana isabella persa
che riprende un ricordo molto
particolare di eisler la bambina che
vedete nel quadro nel dipinto in realtà
è eisler e poco prima di che la sua vita
fosse sconvolta da e anche come avrebbe
distrutto la vita di milioni di persone
nel viaggio verso la partnership eisler
parla delle sette relazioni della nostra
vita
esploriamo le insieme la prima in
rapporto con noi stessi e noi stesse il
corpo la mente e lo spirito ne abbiamo
sentito parlare anche prima e a partire
da questa relazione che il centro
partnership stabia che dirigo ha
realizzato un laboratorio artistico
virtuale
nel rapporto fra tecnologie umane e
digitali per riportarci al sapere che i
nostri corpi viventi devono comunque
mantenere questa qualità all'interno di
una società troppo spesso solo ed
esclusivamente virtuale
le artiste tiziana isabella persa
insieme al collettivo dalla maschera al
volto coordinato da alessandro rinaldi
hanno realizzato durante conoscenza in
festa una diciamo delle cartoline per
pubblicizzare questa iniziativa e come
vedete c'è un neon che si intitola
living boris ler in rima l'itis proprio
per definire questa relazione
in quell'occasione c'è stata una
transfomers a cura di mattia mantellato
e uno solita el in coordinato da piero
giacconi per ricordarci la bellezza
l'importanza dello sguardo del movimento
del corpo della voce degli occhi
dell'anima
riviviamo insieme oggi un breve momento
di questa terra performance
brave le nostre ragazze vero il secondo
tipo di relazioni e di rapporti che
eisner analizza sono i rapporti intimi è
bene riflettere sul modo in cui ci
rapportiamo alle altre e agli altri e
anche con la nostra interiorità ci
relazioniamo con aggressività con
durezza oppure siamo accoglienti ci
incontriamo sappiamo emanare cura e
amore vi racconto un esempio personale
tempo fa avevo un bravissimo studente è
quasi pronto per la laurea che è andato
in crisi come a volte succede e non
riuscivamo ad uscire da questa
problematica quindi avendo creato con
lui un rapporto di fiducia empatico di
cura di attenzione ad un certo punto
avuto un intenso
un'intuizione ho detto ma facciamo un
patto scritto fra noi due abbiamo
sfilato un contratto con le date lo
scadenziario delle date in cui doveva
consegnargli materiale una serie di cose
con documento firma insomma una cosa un
po abbastanza in piena regola
questo stratagemma se volete è servito a
a spostare il meccanismo dell'attenzione
dalla paura dallo stress di concludere
al farlo con un grande successo con un
bel 110 e lode e quindi questo è un modo
in cui si può lavorare in questo volume
che vedremo perso rapporto è quello con
la comunità che è un cerchio sempre più
ampio della cura nel volume la vera
ricchezza delle nazioni sempre di eisler
eisler parla dell'economia di cura e
sottolinea l'importanza dei lavori di
cura che sono fondamentali come
l'insegnamento prendersi cura dei
bambini ed ai bambini e degli anziani
che spesso però viene un po trascurato
viene visto viene sottopagato e visto
come non così importante nei rapporti
con la comunità è fondamentale
creare fiducia e empatia rispetto
comprensione solo così possiamo
manifestare la partnership altro
rapporto numero 4 i rapporti con la
comunità perché la politica conta primo
passo che dobbiamo fare è ricordarci e
sapere nella consapevolezza che possiamo
insieme fare la differenza possiamo e
dobbiamo anche avere impegnarci con
forza per un'agenda politica integrata
di partnership che su quelli che a esame
chiama e quattro pilastri della
partnership i rapporti di infanzia
mutuali perché nei rapporti con bambini
e bambine impariamo poi relazionarci da
adulti i rapporti di genere e mutuali
purtroppo stiamo vedendo no tuttora una
forte recrudescenza di femminicidi
ovviamente se non impariamo da piccoli
da piccole a relazionarci abbiamo
difficoltà l'economia mutuale come vi
dicevo prima un'economia di cura che
pensi alla sostenibilità delle cose è
importantissimo il quarto la quarta
credenza quelle la credenza culturale il
mito la storia che siano a supporto
della partnership importante è quello
che ci raccontiamo sulla nostra vita per
parlare dei rapporti con la comunità
internazionale con il mondo intorno a
noi rivoluziona un po come spesso fa in
tutti i suoi libri le nostre abitudini
di pensiero indica il prevalere di
quello che lei chiama il modello di
dominio in società apparentemente che
noi giudicheremo diverse distanti dal
punto di vista culturale storico
geografico è infatti dice così non
esiste differenza fra la germania di
hitler
l'iran di khomeini il giappone dei
samurai gli aztechi della mesoamerica la
cina di mao il fondamentalismo religioso
di qualunque
colore tutte queste società per altri
versi molto diverse sono rigidamente a
dominio maschile possiedono la struttura
gerarchica e un alto grado di violenza
quindi quando sentiamo le news
televisione siamo con partecipe di
quello che accade se sentiamo parlare
della fame nel mondo e violenza verso le
donne dai danni umani artistici
planetari delle guerre dell'inquinamento
della globalizzazione dello sfruttamento
non è una statistica anonima riguarda
noi altrettanto importante è il rapporto
con la natura con la madre terra
osservare il cosmo con le sue dimensioni
vedete quante piccina la terra mi aiuta
sempre un po a ridimensionare le
questioni ad avere una prospettiva
diversa relativa e la partnership si
diceva comincia da noi per le sei
nazioni native irochesi bambine e
bambini devono essere il fulcro di ogni
nostro pensiero devono portarci ad
assumere le nostre decisioni politiche
ed i legali pensando alle generazioni
future nel rispetto della madre terra
della vita del bene comune
nella settima relazione è quella
spirituale possiamo ricordare insieme a
tutti i popoli nativi che è fondamentale
tutelare e celebrare la bellezza è il
miracolo della vita e dell'amore in una
società sempre più frenetica e iper
tecnologica e iper razionalista è bene
imparare ricordare di fermarci
allora facciamolo insieme fermiamoci
chiudete gli occhi e seguitemi sentite
percepite la tensione del vostro respiro
la tensione della vostra postura sulle
sedie quindi un po la chiusura noi
tendiamo a respirare
sempre con una parte alta dei polmoni e
inspirate profondamente ed espirate
profondamente per due o tre volte
fate un bel respiro profondo inspirate
ed espirate adesso semplicemente in modo
naturale lasciate che il respiro fluisca
e concentratevi sul respiro i clan
monaco vietnamita di c'è una cosa che mi
piace molto
inaliamo calma e saliamo sorrisi
dovremmo ricordarcelo spesso in
conclusione se volete riaprire gli occhi
riprendere un po contatto con il vostro
corpo con l'ambiente percepite una
differenza
dentro di voi e forse anche
nell'ambiente ovviamente lo abbiamo
dovuto attendere molto breve questa
questo tecnico però la potete ripetere
tranquillamente in qualunque occasione e
in qualunque circostanza
in conclusione desidero raccontarvi una
storia che mi è molto cara e che
troviamo nel libro donne che corrono coi
lupi di pinkola estès si intitola tra i
capelli d'oro piccole stress come aisla
è stata per me personalmente una lettura
trasformativa importante questa storia
in particolare una storia di
rigenerazione di trasformazione ci parla
del bisogno ciclico e circolare di una
persona che ciculi e che ci prenda cura
si prenda cura di noi
c'era una volta in una notte nera e
profonda un vecchio che attraversava
barcollando un fitto bosco teneva in
mano una candela che emanava una luce
sempre più fioca il vecchio aveva lunghi
capelli gialli e denti gialli era curvo
e avanzava con una enorme fatica
infine in lontananza vite una piccola
luce una casetta si diresse li
arrancando e trascinando il suo corpo
sempre più esausto quando arriva la
porta crollò sfinito la vecchia padrona
della casetta lo prese in braccio e lo
portò accanto al suo bel fuoco urgente
si sedette su una sedia a dondolo con il
vecchio in braccio e lo collo come una
grande madre
immaginateli il povero vecchio boss era
forte vecchia che lo culla va avanti
indietro avanti e indietro
ripetendo ecco ecco ecco lo usò per
tutta la notte e amano umano il vecchio
si era trasformato prima in un adulto
poi in un bel giovane finché all'alba
era divenuto un bel bimbetto neonato la
vecchia allora gli strappò da la
testolina adorata tre capelli d'oro e li
gettò il terra i tre capelli cadendo
fecero un bel tintinnio fresco e
cristallino il bimbo scivola giù dal
grembo della vecchia corsi alla porta si
girò a guardarla e sorrise di un sorriso
luminosissimo poi si volse è salito in
cielo per diventare lo splendido sole
del mattino
grazie
per il dono del nostro tempo
[Applauso]